[Music]
I listen to the scientists this morning
Rick and dr. malice was talking about
his those experiments and I realized
that I almost became a scientist when I
was 14 my parents bought me a chemistry
set
and I decided to make water
[Laughter]
so I made a hydrogen generator and I
made an oxygen generator and I had the
two pipes leading into a beaker and I
throw a match in and the blasts luckily
I turned around I had it all in my back
and it was about 15 feet away the wall
was covered with I had an explosion
people on the street came and knocked on
the door to see if I was okay so I'd
like to start a various start this
session again the gentleman to my left
is the the very famous perhaps overly
famous Frank Gehry and Frank you have
come to a place in your life which is
astonishing I mean it is astonishing for
an artist for an architect to become
actually an icon and a legend in their
own time I mean you have become whether
you can giggle at it because it's a
funny you know the strange thought but
your building is an icon you can draw a
little picture of that building can be
used in ads and you've had not Rockstar
status but celebrity status in doing
what you wanted to do for most of your
life and I know the road was extremely
difficult and it didn't seem at least
that that your sellouts whatever they
were were very big that you kept moving
ahead in a you know in a life where
you're dependent on working for somebody
hmm right but that's an interesting
thing for a creative person a lot of us
work for people we are in the hands of
other people and that's one of the great
dilemmas we're in a creativity session
it's one of the great dilemmas and
creativity how did the work that's big
enough and not sellout and you've
achieved that and that makes your win
doubly big Triple E big it's not quite a
question but you can comment on that's
it's a big issue yeah
well I've always just I've never really
gone out looking for work I always
waited for it to sort of hit me on the
head and when I started out I thought I
was that architecture was a service
business and that you had to please the
clients and stuff and I realized when
I'd come into the meetings with these
corrugated metal and chain-link stuff
and people would just look at me like I
just landed from Mars but I couldn't do
anything else I just that was my
response to the people in the time and
actually it was responding to clients
that I had heard that didn't have very
much money so they couldn't afford very
much I think was circumstantial until I
got to my house where the client was my
wife
we bought this tiny little bungalow and
Santa Monica and for like 50 grand I
built a house around it and a few people
got excited about it I was visiting with
an artist Michael Heizer out in the
desert near Las Vegas somewhere he's
building this huge concrete place and it
was late in the evening we'd had a lot
to drink we were standing out in the
desert all alone and he said thinking
about my house he said that ever occur
to you if you built stuff more permanent
somewhere in 2000 years somebody's going
to like it
so I thought yeah it's probably a good
idea
luckily I started to get some clients
add a little more money so this stuff
was a little more permanent but I just
found out the world ain't gonna last
that long if the guy was telling us the
other day so where do we go now back to
temper everything's so temporary I don't
see it the way you characterized it
Richard obviously I'm for me every day
is a new thing I approach each project
with a new insecurity almost like the
first project I ever did and I get the
sweats I go in and start working I'm not
sure where I'm going if I knew where I
was going I wouldn't do it when I when I
can predict or plan it I don't do it I
don't discard it
so I approach it with the same
trepidation I mean obviously over time
there's a lot I have a lot more
confidence that it's gonna be okay I do
run a kind of a business I got 120
people and you got paid them and so
there's a lot of responsibility involved
but the work the actual work on the
project is what I think a healthy and
security and like the playwright said
the other day I could relate to him that
you're not sure and when you look at it
when when Bilbao was finished and I
looked at I saw them steaks I saw they
weren't mistakes I saw everything that I
would have changed and I thought of it I
was in fact I was embarrassed by it I
felt an embarrassment how could I have
done that how could I put made shapes
like that or done stuff like that it's
taken several years to now look at it
detached and say as you walk around the
corner and a piece of it works with the
road and the street and it appears to
have a relationship that I started to
like it
what's the status of the New York
project I don't really know
Tom cremes came to me with Bilbao
and explained it all to me and and I
thought he was nuts and I didn't think
he knew what he was doing and he pulled
it off so I think he's Icarus and
Phoenix all-in-one guy
and he gets up there and then he comes
back up they're still talking about it
let's say September 11 generated some
interest in moving it over to to Ground
Zero and I'm totally against that but I
just feel uncomfortable talking about or
building anything on Ground Zero I think
for a lot of long time maybe the picture
on the screen is of the Disney is that
Disney yep how much further along is it
that than that and when will that be
finished they'll be finished in 2003
September October and I'm hoping cue and
Herbie and yo-yo and all those guys come
play with us at that place luckily today
I most of the people I'm working with
are people I really like Richard Kirsch
aaalac is probably one of the main
reasons that Disney Hall came to me he's
been a cheerleader for quite a long time
there aren't there aren't many people
around that are really involved with
architecture as clients you know if you
think about the the world and even just
in this audience most of us are involved
with buildings not with our nothing that
you would call architecture right and so
to find one a guy like that you hang on
to them you know he he's become the head
of Art Center and he's and there's a
building by Craig Elwood there and I
knew Craig and and respected him and
they want to add to it and it's hard to
add to a building like that it's a
beautiful minimalist black steel
building and Richard wants to add a
library and more student stuff and it's
a lot of acreage and I convinced him to
let me bring in another architect from
Portugal Alvaro Siza why'd you want that
I knew you'd ask that question
it was intuitive albro Cesar grew up and
lived in Portugal and is probably the
considered Portuguese main guy in
architecture I visited with him a few
years ago and he showed me his early
work and his early work had a
resemblance to my early work and it had
to be had to go when I came out of
college I started to try to do things
contextually in Southern California and
you got into the the logic of Spanish
colonial tile roofs and things like that
and I tried to understand that language
as a beginning as a place to jump off
and there were there was so much of it
being done by spec builders and and and
it was trivialized so much that it it
wasn't
I just stopped I mean Charlie more did a
bunch of it but it didn't feel good to
me seas on the other hand continued
imported Portugal where the real stuff
was and evolved a modern language that
relates to that that historic language
and I always felt that he should come to
Southern California do a building and I
tried to get him a couple of jobs they
didn't pan out and I liked the idea of
collaboration with with people like that
because
it pushes you it's like I've done it
with Klaus Oldenburg and and with
Richard Serra who doesn't think I'm
gonna doesn't think architectures are
did you see that thing mm-hmm
what'd he say he calls architecture
plumbing anyway the the season thing the
it's a richer experiment must be like
that fork you doing things with
musicians it's similar to that I would
imagine where you you huh
liquid architect where you
it's like jazz you improvise you work
together you play off each other you you
make something they make something and I
think it's a way of for me it's a way of
trying to understand the city and what
might what might happen in the city and
is it going to be near the current
campus or is it going to be down here
oh it's near the Kerr count anyway he's
he's that kind of patron it's not his
money of course what's this what there
that I don't know what's the schedule
urgent
you can come to the opening only no but
the issue of city building in democracy
is interesting because it it creates
chaos right ever everybody doing their
thing makes a very chaotic environment
and if you can figure out how to work
off each other
I mean it's not that that you can get a
bunch of people who respect each other's
work and play off each other you might
be able to create models for for how to
build sections of the city without
resorting to the one architect like the
Rockefeller Center model which is kind
of from another era I found the most
remarkable thing
my preconception of Bilbao was this
wonderful building go inside and it'd be
extraordinary spaces I'd seen drawings
you would presented here it Ted the
surprise that Bilbao was in its context
to the city yeah that was the surprise
of going across the river of going on
the highway around it of walking down
the street and finding it that was the
real surprise of Bilbao but you know
we're richard most architects when they
present their work most of the people we
know yeah you get up and you talk about
your work and you talk about it's almost
like you you tell everybody you're
you're a good guy by saying look I'm I'm
worried about the context I'm worried
about the city I'm worried about my
client I worry about budget I'm on time
and all that stuff and it's like
cleansing yourself so that you can and
by saying all of that means your your
your work is good somehow and I think
everybody I mean that should be a matter
of fact like gravity you should
you're not gonna defy gravity gravity
you got to work with the building
department if you don't meet the budgets
you're not gonna get much work if you
don't if it if it leaks
bill Bell did not leak that I was so
proud the MIT project they were
interviewing me for MIT and they they
sent there their facilities people to
Bilbao I met them in Bilbao they came
for three days this is the computer
building yeah the computer they were
there three days and it rained every day
and they've kept walking around I
noticed they were looking under things
and looking for thing and they wanted to
know where the buckets were hidden you
know people put buckets of them I was
clean there wasn't a bloody leak in the
place it was just fantastic but you've
got it
yeah well up until then every building
leak so this Frank had a sort of ask
Miriam his fame was built on that in LA
for well you know frankly you've all
heard the Frank Lloyd Wright story when
the guy the woman called and said mr.
Wright my my I'm sitting in the couch
and the water is pouring it on my head
and he said madam move your chair so
some years later I was doing a build a
little house on the beach for Norton
Simon and his secretary who was kind of
a hell on wheels type lady called me and
said mr. Simon sitting at his desk and
that the water is coming in on his head
and I told her the Frank Lloyd Wright
story didn't get a laugh though not now
either
[Laughter]
but but my point is that and I call it
the then what okay you solved all the
problems you did all this stuff you made
nice you love your clients you love the
but you love the city you're a good guy
you're a good person and then what what
do you what do you bring to it and I
think that's what I've always been
interested in is that P which is a
personal kind of expression and it
Bilbao I think shows that you can have
that kind of personal expression and
still touch all the bases that are
necessary of fitting into the city like
that's what reminded me of it so and I
think that's that's the issue you know
and that's the then what that most
clients who hire architects most clients
aren't hiring architects for that
they're hiring them to get it done get
it on budget you know not you know be
polite and they're missing out on the
real value of an architect at a certain
point a number of years ago people when
Michael Graves was a fashion before
teapots I did a teapot and nobody bought
it you didn't leak No
that people wanted a Michael Graves
building is that a curse that people
want a Bilbao building yeah I've gotten
called since Bilbao opened which is now
four or five years or anything thank you
sorry I don't both cremes and I have
been called with I don't know at least a
hundred opportunities China Brazil Park
other parts of Spain to come in and do
the Bilbao effect and some I I've met
with some of some of these people
usually I say no right away but some of
them come with pedigree and and they
sound well-intentioned and they they get
you for at least one or two meetings in
one case I flew all the way to Malaga
with a team because it was thought the
thing was signed by with seals and very
you know very official seals from the
city and that they wanted me to come and
do a building in their port and I asked
what kind of building it was when you
get here we'll explain in manova so four
of us went and they took us they put us
up in a great hotel and we were looking
over the the bay and then they took us
in a boat out in the water and showed us
all these sites in the harbor and each
one was more beautiful than the other
and then we were gonna have lunch with
the mayor and we were gonna have dinner
with the most important people in Malaga
and just before we going to lunch with
the mayor we went to the harbor
commissioner and it was a table as long
as this carpet and the harbor
commissioner was here and I was here my
guys and
we sat down we had a drink of water and
everybody was quiet and the guy looked
at me and said now what can I do for you
mr. Garre oh my god so I got up I said
to my team let's get out of here we
stood up we walked out they followed the
guy that dragged us there follows he
said you mean you're not gonna have
lunch with the mayor I said nope you're
not gonna have dinner with all they just
brought us there to hustle at this group
you know to create a project and we get
a lot of them and you got a really
luckily I'm old enough that I you know I
can complain I can't travel I don't have
my own plane yet but well I'm gonna wind
this up and wind up the meeting because
it's been very long but let me just say
a couple words can I say something
are you gonna talk about me are you
[Applause]
once a always a no because I
want I want to get a standing ovation
like everybody
[Applause]